hopefully by now you've seen our video
on what Graham's number is if you
haven't it's the number of dimensions
that a cube must exist in before a
certain configuration of colored lines
between as vertices must exist now this
number is famously very very big how big
is it well we're going to let the man
who first wrapped his head around it run
Graham explain it to you
well I can't really write it yet I have
to explain the notation okay so we need
some notation so called arrow notation
and often attributed to Don Knuth
computer science at the Stanford is very
creative about notation and the notation
is this so suppose you write three
arrows M that just stands for three to
the power n ok so three arrows 10 is 3
to the 10th power that's a pretty big
number ok so that's why do you need
arrows to write 3 to the N well you know
ok well what do you mean by three two
arrows and well what that means is 3 to
the arrow of 3 to the arrow of 3 to the
arrow of dot dot 3 to the arrow of 3 and
there are n threes so ok so what does
this mean 3 to the arrow of 3 is what
well it's 3 to the 3 3 to that arrow is
3 to the 3 3 to that arrow 3 to the 3 so
it's a tower of 3 to the 3 to the 3 to
the 3 there are n threes so for example
three double arrows three how much is
that well that's three single arrow
three single arrow 3 or 3 to the 3 this
is 3 3 to the 3 is 27 3 to 27 which is 3
to the 27 or 3 to the 3 to the 3 3 to
the 27th power is a pretty big number I
think it's worth stopping here for just
a moment to let things start sinking in
two threes with one arrow between ER
that's 27 put two arrows between them
and things escalate to up over seven
trillion that's a pretty quick
escalation what happens if we use three
arrows so this is three double arrow
of three double-arrow of three what is
three double arrows three
well it's 3 to the 3 to the 3 okay 3 to
the 27 so this is three double rows of
anything is 3 to the 3 to the 3 to the 3
to the 3 and how many 3 to the 27 3 to
the 3 to the 3 to the 30th of that 3 the
27th power well that's getting to be a
pretty big number yeah so three arrows
has given us a number so big I can't
even write it on the screen
except maybe like this okay so now I
think we ran out of this piece of paper
actually you look yeah I think we you
ain't seen nothing yet
okay so here we go three four F one more
error well what does this mean three
three arrows of three three arrows of
three well this is three triple arrow of
something what is this number and you
saw this number right here right this is
3 to the 3 to the 3 to the 3 to the 3
well okay so what is three triple arrow
of anything mean it's three double
arrows of three double arrows of three
double arrows Oh fine at the M 3 double
arrows three and how many threes this
many threes so it's a pretty big number
this is 3 to the 3 3 to the 27th and
this is a tower of that high 3 to the 3
to the 3
that's this 3 to that and then the next
one is a tower of that height in the
next one is a tower of that height and
you repeat this for 3 to the 3 to the 3
to the 3 to the 27 times so
that many layers each one tells you the
number of threes and the layer below now
four arrows has given us a number so big
that mere mortals like us shouldn't even
bother trying to imagine it you can see
I've just used the term insane number
and by the way we're not even in the
ballpark of Graham's number yet now what
does this final number we're looking at
this so called Graham's number it's a
three for arrows three that's a big
number but what it represents is the
number of arrows between these two
threes remember each additional arrow
put you into a much bigger world well
now how many arrows do you have well
this many but that's a big number so I
hope you grasp that adding just one
arrow takes things up by a crazy amount
now we've got two threes and the number
of arrows between them is the insane
number that I couldn't even write down
and that's the number of arrows but
that's not it once you take that three
insane arrow three number you spit out
another number at the end that I don't
even want to think about that one you
then take that number and now that's the
number of arrows between the threes and
then you repeat that again and again and
again and each number tells you how many
arrows are in the thing just below it
and you keep this process up each one
telling you how many arrows 64 levels
that's the definition of the Screamers
so already to understand three four
arrows three is not so easy but when you
see that's how many arrows are in this
number and then that number is how many
arrows in the 1 and so forth it's a I
think it's unlikely anyone will know the
leading digit of this number
the last digit you can actually get the
last I think there's a list the last 500
digits you can't because it turns out
you take a big enough power of three the
last digits
and are very predictable but the first
digit I don't know and it's your number
what do you want it to first digit to be
well in binary it's one so there you go
so there we go grams number and if you
think you understand it you probably
don't and this is the upper bound on the
number of dimensions that a cube lives
in to force this configuration of lines
between vertices you can see the other
video to have it explained it's the
upper bound now we know it doesn't work
in twelve dimensions but it could work
in thirteen dimensions could be yeah
could be 13 that's definitely less than
definitely less than that yeah so the
it's called a small gap in our knowledge
somewhere between 13 and Graham's number
now Graham's number was once in the
Guinness Book of Records as the biggest
number ever used in a sort of
constructive proof it's since been
surpassed by other mathematicians but
Graham's number was the first of these
big boys and it still got that bit of
glamour involved with it if you'd like
to find out more about the number check
out our original video from a couple of
years ago Ron Graham explaining what
Graham's number is and also some extra
footage from Ron Graham that ended up on
my virtual cutting room floor you can
check them out there are links on the
screen and underneath and thanks a lot
to Ron Graham for telling us all about
Graham's number